and so it's a legacy thing and creating
a family that sticks together and has
certain family values that can literally
Propel into the future it normally it
takes a couple generations to create a
Rockefeller type family and so if if
people start today building that Legacy
then it's a really huge thing in fact I
just got a text yesterday from NBA
player who wants to like talk business
about something I knew who he was
because he was in the league but his
father and grandfather own a large
portion of real estate in Baton Rouge
and I knew who they were just from the
real estate world and so when Kyle is
his name's Carlos Temple he's been he's
the class he's my favorite NBA player
not because he's the best players
because he's a Class Act
gentleman you know what I'm saying like
yes I'll do whatever whatever College
wants to do Let's Do It Let's do let's
make money bro and my suit guy's a black
guy he knew him he gave me my cell phone
number the guy that made this suit black
guy right gave me the contact to plug I
don't care because money is green